These myths of threats
They first materialized on my earth many years ago. I was part of the last battalion life trying to stop them
All we did was delay the inevitable the elementals are here now attacking the same coordinates our satellites confirm it we have one mission
Kill it
You're coming with us. It's a fury this all seems like big time, you know, huge superhero kind of stuff and I
Mean, I'm just a friendly neighborhood spider-man sir. It's please you've been to space
Fury asked me to come up here and see how you were doing. He just he felt bad about snapping at ya
Subtitle-*I am HeRe* in description at last
Really you guys do have sarcasm on this earth, right?
How you feeling I
Didn't think I was gonna have to save the world too, sir. I know that makes me sound like such a jerk. I just I
Had this plan with this girl that I really like him now it's all ruined I
Like you Peter a good kid
There's a part of me that wants me to tell you just
Turn around run away from all this and then there's another part of me that knows what we're about to fight
What's at stake? I'm glad you're here
Me too, but you're worried about your friends. Yeah
Just always feel like I'm putting them in danger
look just
Get him inside and keep them in a safe place for just a few hours and they'll be alright
It's really nice to have somebody to talk to you about superhero stuff, you know
Any time, okay
Beat the rush here to rush out lucky for us. We got the best seats in the house
Let's go
You look really pretty and therefore I have value no, no, that's not what I meant at all. I was just I'm messing with you
Thank you
You're welcome
You look pretty too my glasses. So cute. You want to go in on a pair?
You mean that's it next to each other. Yeah
No, okay, no
Wanna sit here, you just don't I didn't mean that if you go ahead I'll go grab us a beer
No, I'm coming
What is going on these things destroyed my world
Snap to a hole in our dimension now this threat is here the worlds in chaos. I need a new team
I need an Avenger. What about the offworld? Dr. Strange unavailable chat tomorrow don't invoke Rene
Mr. Stark trusted me
I'm not gonna let him down
We have to stop them
Welcoming the Avengers
Get gifts Parker the world needs that
I've got this
Hey everybody its charlie we have a whole bunch of spider-man far from home trailers and scenes to break down
There's also a bunch of big Marvel news that dropped this morning about comic-con. Marvel will be going they confirm their panel
I'll talk about that at the end of the video. Kevin Feige was also talking about x-men characters coming into the MCU
So it's actually a really big day for Marvel fans
There's a new round of that spider-man far from home imax ticket giveaway
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber and leave a spider-man comment on the video
I'll name a new winner at the end of this welcome to The Avengers Mysterio. I'm sure this totally won't go off the rails
What a great idea spider-man feels like he's justified in minting a brand new Avenger
I guess because he's one of the only ones around love the Doctor Strange
Name-dropped - I'll explain that there's actually a big theory about the plot of the Doctor Strange movie that involves spider-man far from home
But we start with the clip of Mysterio explaining his backstory in much greater
detail about how the
elementals destroyed his world and he was the last of a group of Heroes last of whatever his world's version of the Avengers was they
Tried to save it. They were too late
You kind of see the metaphor they're going for because this is happening after the events of Avengers endgame
they want to make it seem like
That was a version of an earth where Thanos wound up winning and destroying the entire planet only
It was just the elementals that were causing all the damage and now they're going to the same
locations where they destroyed that other world on our earth
Then there's a scene of Mysterio going to talk to Peter on the bridge which seems like it's a little bit later in the film
After he's just been chewed out by Nick Fury for refusing the hero's call
It sounds like he spends a lot of the early part of the film refusing that call or put a new team together
I'm sorry. I'm busy. I'm on my summer vacation. I have all this PTSD from watching my surrogate father iron, man
Die in my arms just a couple months ago
the whole idea being that
Mysterio is supposed to be the cool uncle - iron man's father figure giving spider-man someone to talk to when he's all bummed out about
Hero stuff that also understands what he's going through
So one of his big arcs during the film is dealing with the trauma and the grief of losing Iron Man
But his bummed out as he seems in a lot of these scenes
I don't think that they're taking it to Tobey Maguire levels of a Spider Man being bummed out of all the live-action
Ones at least he's probably been the most bummed out of all the spider-man that we've gotten so far
Speaking of which there was actually somebody during the press junkets recently that asked Tom Holland if he wanted to do a crossover
With Andrew Garfield spider-man in Tobey Maguire spider-man a big multiverse crossover, of course
He said yes any chance there's a multiverse in which Andrew Garfield spider-man until you acquire spider-man and help your spider-man all meet together
clashing
But would you want that though, would you want that's it. Maybe that's a better question
What do we want that the thing about this film? That's so exciting. Right is we take spider-man to Europe?
And what's so cool about that. You've never seen spider-man in Europe before now, of course, I'd love to make
It would be really really cool something the fans really want so whether Marvel and Sony decide to do that
It's not up to me I thought walking like Kevin this is what we're doing on the next one. Yeah, but it would be
Then they go into the scene of them at the Opera is just a bit of a funny moment with Peter trying to balance both
Of his lives trying to do spider-man stuff with Nick Fury yelling in his ear
While they're in the middle of a big tactical situation and also try to make time with his lady
MJ who's still at this point in the film hasn't figured out that he's spider-man
But clearly from the way they leave the scene
You can see that he's going to have to ghost her during this performance and she'll just wonder where he went
Just like she did at the end of the first film
What are you hiding Peter
I'm just
So they're just trying to continue that idea that she's very
observant
And she does kind of like Peter so she pays attention
To what he's doing at all times and she just happens to notice it
He always seems to duck out when really big things are happening
So that's part of the reason that Nick Fury gives him the stealth suit during the film so that other people also don't start figuring
Out that he's spider-man because he keeps popping up everywhere these elementals pop up in spider-man as well
They keep showing the footage of the old Avengers tower
So I think it's safe to say that at least one of the post-credits scenes is going to be a big reveal of who bought
It from Iron Man remember, they would have to be crazy rich, so it's probably quote-unquote a corporation
I'm sure we're all here a bunch of theories about that in the next week or two
There's a very big superhero landing in the new Steve Ditko suit love the new footage of that funny montage scene of spider-man
referencing all the different characters including Doctor Strange
So they changed the line from Captain Marvel as well to they'd actually covered up the Doctor Strange line
maybe because when they first released that clip
It was because it was right after Avengers endgame came out of theaters and they didn't want to completely give away
The Doctor Strange was coming back. But the new line is as Captain Marvel
Don't invoke her name the big Doctor Strange rumor though
The reason why he isn't available to help out during the events of this movie is because it takes place concurrently
With the events of Doctor Strange to which they haven't started filming yet. That movie is not going to be released till like 2021
I think but during that movie Doctor Strange is supposed to be trapped in the dream dimension by the villain who is nightmare
This is the director talking about that last year
I really like the character of nightmare and the concept that the nightmare nightmare realm is a dimension
I always thought that was one of the that's early that's like in the first strange tale, I think
That's an introductory EPS episode of Doctor Strange and I always loved that then spider-man infamously
We should say inducks Mysterio to the Avengers
So of course that's going to bite him in the ass by the end of the movie
But this seems like it's pretty early with them bonding spider-man grows really close to him
So that whatever big betrayal they might have later in the film lands way harder on spider-man
There's a much longer scene of him swinging through the buildings in New York City. Probably towards the end of the film
I do like the physics of this version of spider-man in this movie
I feel like the gun much better at that since way back in the Tobey Maguire era
Remember Kirsten Dunst with the mannequin when they would do those swinging scenes. Sometimes her hair would blow the wrong way
It wouldn't quite make sense
And if you stare at it too long, you can definitely tell that she's holding on to a mannequin and not an actual person
We should still say even though some of the special effects were a little more primitive
Spiderman tube remains one of the best comic book films of all time
Because all the Spiderman far from home junkets are happening right now
They're interviewing all the people Kevin Feige was doing interviews as well - he said some funny stuff about Keanu Reeves just because Keanu Reeves
is on fire right now the feeling of of being there of walking the streets of the future is
Really going to be breathtaking
He said that he's been talking to Keanu Reeves on a regular basis ever since they've been making
Marvel movies looking for a role for him, but it's just taken this long to find the appropriate one
So every time a new phase of films comes up
they always meet with Keanu Reeves to try and talk about something that they might be able to work on together the new movie that
He's supposed to be doing right now is eternals
That's the role that he's up for but we don't know exactly who he would be playing during that do kaboom
Canada's greatest stuntman. Oh
Yeah
Yes
He also said that ever since the Fox deal completed and they got access to all the x-men characters at least on a legal level
They've been having regular meetings with all the executives Marvel Studios
Pitching ideas for x-men inside the MCU whether it be their own solo films or they do the spider-man
Captain America Civil War brown or like black panther where they put them in a much bigger film and then give them their own solo
Film so even though it's gonna take a long time for us to actually see some x-men actually popping up inside Marvel movies
They're talking about it right now. But this is just like very early pitch stage where people are trying to come up with ideas
Why don't we introduce?
Wolverine in the post-credits scene for whatever movie is gonna be right before the next Avengers film then it becomes a much bigger character and
Eventually joins the Avengers or why don't we debut Professor X or Magneto or Kitty Pryde then you can just theory craft from there
So obviously all that's going on behind the scenes right now if you're worried
But he did say that Deadpool is kind of its own separate things
so Deadpool isn't really being considered for a big crossover movie with an MCU character any time soon as I
Making this video. I'm still supposed to go see spider-man far from home
So my non-spoilery early reaction review will post tomorrow too as long as you have alerts enabled for my channel
You'll see that video when I post it. So no worries. It will be non spoilery
We're not really allowed to post really big review videos till the end of the month
Congratulations to the giveaway winner from my last big Marvel video Caleb part production company
Please email me on the about page of my channel so I can get your details
click here for that brand new Avengers endgame deleted scene with Iron Man and Doctor Strange and then click here to learn about the
Alternate ending to Avengers endgame. Thank you so much for watching. Everybody. Stay. Awesome. I'll see you guys tonight